hello fellow soldiers it's Michael
nolles here a general in the war on
Christmas we are all part of Santa's
Army Santa I mean you know actually
Santa does have a religious connection
to the holiday which is about the birth
of our Lord Jesus Christ and the
connection being that Santa is based on
St Nicholas anyway there's very many
interesting things to say about
Christmas and then there are a lot of
uninteresting stupid things to say about
Christmas which is what the libs who are
waging the war on Christmas say all the
time so here is our annual edition of
the liberals latest talking points in
the war on Christmas take it
[Music]
[Applause]
away Taylor this one isn't even original
what is
this because I guess it's supposed to be
subversive in that they took a Christmas
tree and they turned it into a BLM thing
but that's just a a k Quanza decoration
I mean all K Quanza is is a black
identitarian a black liberation movement
guy who was a socialist creating a
socialist Festival to try to replace
Christmas I wish you'd get out of my
life and shut up the guy gave himself
the name Milana Kanga but his real name
is Ron Everett and he was a calstate
Long Beach Professor who was later
arrested for torturing women and
imprisoning them and doing all sorts of
sick crazy things to
them dang and he was a nut and the
holidays ridiculous and no one really
celebrates it at all and BLM is just the
latest version of that I mean they
didn't even change the initialism from
the Black Liberation movement BLM to
Black lives matter BLM Angela Davis said
it's the same thing the people who are
the inspiration of and the leaders of
the black lives matter movement all say
this is the exact same thing as we saw
in the 60s when some other wackos tried
to replace Christmas with a socialist
Festival to whine about how black people
are oppressed uh which isn't even
embraced by the majority of black people
nowhere near it so Zing you got us
[Music]
guys
all it's the celebration of a birth
that's why you don't like it it's true
you probably don't like Christianity or
God or the moral order because you
persisting in something that we all know
including you is obviously wrong it's
terrible to kill a baby it's time to
stop but probably the reason that this
fanatical pro-abortion person really
hates Christmas is that it's the Feast
of the Nativity it's about the birth of
our Lord probably she would do a little
bit better with really any other
Christian Feast Michael miss or you know
Easter or something but Feast of the
Nativity is much
harder Christmas is a social construct
upheld by the bisi in which they exploit
the labor of proletarian workers and cut
down trees to sell to society in a
socially acceptable way to make room for
industry this is all very silly you know
freshman year Marxism like certainly
this person whoever wrote this has never
actually read Carl Marx but has read
maybe part of the Wikipedia page about
Carl Marx or copy tal or something this
is good because I could barely read so
the last part here is the silliest one
she says it's it's so that Society can
cut down trees to make way for industry
they don't just cut down trees in the
Wilderness you get your Christmas trees
from tree farms and when they cut them
down they don't pave it for a parking
lot they grow more trees
more more in fact the tree Christmas
tree industry is responsible for there
being many more trees in the world
because they're growing them because
it's a sustainable renewable resource
because there's a customer out there to
buy it so that part's very very silly a
social construct I mean it's a social
construct in that we live in a society
and 2,000 years ago a child was born in
Bethlehem to a Virgin heralded by a star
and wise men came to worship him and pay
him homage and uh then that child 30
years after the fact had a Ministry and
then three years after that fell into
his passion was crucified died and was
buried and he redeemed mankind on the
cross and rose again on the third day in
accordance with the scriptures his
kingdom will have no end that's what I'm
talking about that's why he's the go and
people recognize that immediately and
continue to recognize that today and
hail him as the Lord of lords and King
of Kings yeah that's true so that's
social and that you know it's like
people were part of that and our Lord
became a person and entered into society
dwelt Among Us right now go to jus.com
nsyt letter y letter T I have got a
Christmas gift idea that is sure to make
you the hero of the Season we all know
the holiday season can be a little bit
hectic the shopping the cooking the long
list of things to do if you're not
because I've discovered a gift that is
both thoughtful and transformative the
gift of Jus cell skincare from now until
Christmas Jus cell's most popular
package has a special discount just for
our listeners at Jus cell.com letter
wild letter te treat yourself and your
loved ones to the absolute best skincare
in the world those troubling forehead
wrinkles Fine Lines skin redness sagging
Jael line will disappear right before
your eyes with genus cell's most popular
collection genus cell promises immediate
effects you will see results in less
than 12 hours guaranteed or your money
back their products use the best stuff
out there on the market the prices are
are incredibly competitive and in fact
they will give you special holiday
discounts because they know even if they
lose money on this order they know that
you are going to keep coming back that
is how good it is go to Jus cell.com
nsyt get this incredible holiday
discount today every order is instantly
upgraded to free express shipping genu
cell.com
nsyt today just a quick Christmas
reminder that Rudolph the rednose
reindeer is not a heartwarming movie
it's a tale of how the ruling class only
celebrates difference once they figure
out how they can exploit it for personal
gain side note did you ever notice how
literally every company changes their
social media bio photo the day after
pride month ends so weird yeah the pride
stuff is terrible and companies exploit
it because they think they can make
money from a degenerate and decadent
Society but they know that most people
don't like that for most of the rest of
the years so they get rid of it the the
point on on Rudolph is a slightly better
point for this guy which is he's saying
that people when they don't adhere to
the Norms of society are sometimes
ostracized or push to the fringes but
then the happy ending here is that the
dentist elf and Rudolph get brought back
into the fold and everyone's really
happy but he sees this is a really bad
ending because he's he's viewing it
through a Marxist lens which is just the
the the factory workers have figured out
how to exploit the labor of the elf
dentist and of Rudolph but where he sees
something very evil I see something
really beautiful where he sees something
economic I see something more fully
human I'm so very very sad which is that
we are not merely individuals this guy
is coming from the position of a radical
individualism that says he doesn't have
any responsibility to his community to
community standards to the moral order
to God to any kind of behavior just I'm
going to do whatever I want and that's
that and you and you better celebrate it
by the way I have no responsibility to
you but you have responsibilities to me
and what I see here though is the fact
that man is actually a political animal
and a social creature and we are made
for society men are not made to go off
and live alone as atomized individuals
and so the happy ending here is that yes
the the elf dentist and Rudolph are they
are a little bit different and that's
okay to be a little bit different but
you have to figure out how you fit in
even with your differences to society or
else you'll be cut off
from what is required for your
flourishing which is society so it's a
good thing they found their way to fit
back in so this is
Bethlehem
who's in the Christmas spirit seems to
me since this is what Christmas is going
to look like in Palestine this year and
since we were going to boycott
capitalism anyway and we were going to
boycott all the companies on the BBS
list seems to me the perfect opportunity
to celebrate the birthday of the most
famous Palestinian who ever lived from
this little town of Bethlehem to make a
big big big noise internationally for
Palestine I don't know about you but I'm
a little cheesed off that Palestine day
just came and went and we didn't hear
about that like weeks in advance at the
UN made a single announcement about it
any time during the ongoing genocide we
would have been in every major city
across America and across the world
protesting it seems to me that this time
we got a whole month to plan and that
means
[Music]
we excuse I don't know about you but all
I want for Christmas is a free Palestine
uh no I'm I'm I'd like some hot cocoa
spend some time with my family maybe go
to midnight mass that'd be nice the
talking point that keeps recurring here
is that Jesus was a Palestinian first of
all anytime you say Jesus was you're
probably missing the mark because the
big takeaway from the story is that he
is but they're not familiar with the
gospels and the way I know that is that
the synoptic gospels begin with a
genealogy of Our Lord that shows quite
clearly he is ethnically tribally a Jew
in the line of King David actually of
all people and he does not descend from
the Philistines that's not the lineage
you can have all sorts of views on the
Israel Palestine conflict but to say
yeah Jesus is a is a cause for palest
Palestinian Muslim political Liberation
what on Earth are you talking about you
don't just get to rewrite Christianity
for that and you don't get to let Hamas
totally off the hook good grief these
people dumb people are always blissfully
unaware of how dumb they they really are
I guess one silver lining of the libs
just being completely distracted this
year is their usual attacks on Christmas
as um you know a pagan holiday or
whatever uh they've ignored those to
make some other stupid point about
Middle Eastern National politics
okay la la
la
[Applause]
[Music]
of